[Musique]
c'est au collège citant du port que
l'élue déléguée à l'éducation du conseil
départemental s'est rendu administratif
de la direction personnel de
l'établissement et élus du port et
chance différents points et sans perdre
de temps
on passe à la cuisine à la cuisine
centrale donc j'ai tout à l'heure
c'était la plus importante de l'île avec
ceux du second degré six mille 500 repas
par jour pour 17 établissements
[Musique]
il faut dire que la collectivité est une
aide précieuse pour la réalisation des
projets et le paradoxe malheureusement
c'est on est un territoire
le boom économique
puis le personnel de l'établissement
nous fait la visite de la cuisine
centrale
cette cuisine qui distribue plus de 6500
euros pas jour à 17 collèges de l'ouest
dois je me dois en tous les cas de
visiter tous les collèges de 70 cette
collègienne je comptais faire aller les
visiter voir ce qui va ce qui ne va pas
là aujourd'hui je suis au collège titan
au port et quand je vois là à l'ombre de
titan fleurissent des talents j'en suis
fort contente pourquoi tout simplement
parce que je me dis que l'équipe
éducative
il veut contribuer à faire de nos
enfants des experts et c'est ça
aujourd'hui et le département
nous nous voulons construire avec
l'établissement avec l'équipe éducative
pour que nos enfants puissent de mecs
avoir un avenir
la qualité du stati veine et rationnelle
des repas produits et ses habits
quotidiennement par les cuisines sont
les gages d'un mieux-être du jeune dans
sa construction corporelle et
intellectuelle écoutez moi je dis avec
la rencontre aujourd'hui avec ma
collègue marie line vice président du
département
il est important qu'on puisse trouver le
bon maillage avec le crac du pot qui
sont des quartiers prioritaires pour
pouvoir effectivement que le portois les
élèves vaudois profitent de cet outil
qui est un outil éducatif
c'est très moderne et à l'époque si on
nous a mon âge on avait 7 à cette
opportunité franchement on ne
résignerait motiver à rester à la
cantine c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
mamaev on y mange un cantine parce qu'il
veut vraiment le coup et parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez les parents un
repas très diététique et il faut
encourager vos enfants à manger à la
cantine
[Musique]